it's the video the families of the
Uvalde victims have been fighting to see
showing for the first time the horror
which unfolded inside Rob Elementary
School
here 18 year old gunman Salvador Ramos
strolls down the hallway he walks
towards the classroom where he will
murder 19 children and two teachers a
young boy comes around the corner he
survives scarred like so many by what he
saw
two and a half minutes later the first
police officers arrived to approach the
classroom but soon retreat
their colleagues hang back
they're joined by several more carrying
guns wearing body armor even ballistic
Shields
their training makes it clear they
should confront the threat immediately
but in the absence of any apparent
effective leadership they don't
56 minutes into the murderous Rampage
another officer stops to get hand
sanitizer
it's another 20 minutes before they
finally enter the classroom and kill the
gunman
it's a brief families the video confirms
an excruciating and deeply infuriating
timeline how many more kids have to die
before people start standing up you
think that oh this doesn't happen to me
or doesn't happen here or anything until
it does
and it will it's not a matter of if it's
a matter of when
we have to do something
to get
to stop these kids dying
with every new detail about this
shooting a community forced to relive
its Darkest Day and to the crisis
response team demands that their
mistakes be acknowledged Martha Kellner
Sky News